the winning characteristics for a
fencer 60
absolutely determination and you must have a
constant desire to do well and to win
absolutely
and now that I thank you nothing has changed
the desire to win let's say it is
always the
same my name de vivo 20 years and I make a
screen
I started fencing that I had
five years ago I was doing standing then in
2008 I also had a
Flemish coconut disease and then I lost my
hands both legs
it was a difficult situation and for
everything I was doing I was doing it
to go back to doing  screen maybe
let's say you were starting to make schemes
after the illness was a good jerk
because there is no one in the world without the
armed arm from the one
holding a sword and saber foil
based on what you
do breastfeeding great  was able
to invent together with the o paiting
prostheses a prosthesis that would allow me
to do fencing, in short, in a year
we have overcome everything well thanks  and
I won the 2016 rio olympics to the family
the feeling after winning the gold
was a big mess
I couldn't stop crying
muggings to stop screaming
five years ago I never imagined
but every year I think I point more and more
high and I know where I want to go
and I know that I will do everything to get there
[Music]